[Musique]
mais
ôtez maroni qu'est-ce qu'on va découvrir
aujourd'hui talus alexandre aujourd'hui
j'ai parlé d'un super un dispositif pour
le retour à l'emploi le r plus le
ailleurs quoi le r plus mon cap
m'inquiète pas dana stone doit
comprendre si vous êtes bénéficiaire du
rsa et que vous voulez vous aussi
découvrir plus alors venez avec moi
[Musique]
reprise sans compter un engagement entre
les bénéficiaires et le département
l'objectif encourager la reprise
d'activité qu'il s'agit d'une formation
d'un emploi ou d'une création
d'entreprise marie a justement lancé son
appel à quelques temps et elle va nous
en parler bonjour marie pozo maroni
explique hanno après ses rôles et a plus
alors la puce est un dispositif
que milena par rapport à mon activité ça
fait pas longtemps que m'a ouvert mon
activité indépendante de massage donc il
permet à moins d'avoir un revenu
de complément par rapport au chiffre
d'affaires qui des fois l'état facile à
maintenir de l'été avoir bénéficié du
rsa on a eu envie de créer une
entreprise place que l'entreprise est
apprécié la en complément pride house et
ça à oui ça a permet d'avoir un revenu
complémentaire
c'est un beau tremplin et au parlant de
tremplin quel est l'objectif final c'est
vrai sur ce revenu ils permettent à
moins de développer mon antre de mon
entreprise pas d'être assez indépendant
financièrement agrandir mon
mon activité et voler de mes propres
ailes
mes filles mais c'est maroni
quatre parfois entrer dans ce dispositif
vous avez un projet de formation
rémunérée ou bien de mobilité
professionnelle
si vous avez trouvé un emploi en
entreprise ou si vous avez créé votre
propre activité ce soutien financier
lancé à la fin de l'année 2020 est
aujourd'hui utilisé par plus de 4400
réunionnais bourgeois terry aujourd'hui
rené qu'elles soient les modalités de ce
dispositif
alors pour pouvoir bénéficier de ce
dispositif les personnes intéressées par
une reprise d'activité doivent
s'adresser au numéro vert donc du
département où ils seront mis en contact
avec un considérations qui pourra
travailler avec sur leur projet
d'insertion et leur faire les faire
émarger au dispositif quel est le
montant maximum pas bénéficiaire le
montant maximum est de 560 euros et le
montant qui sera donc dévolu à chaque
bénéficiaire sera calculée sur la moitié
des revenus qui leur a généré dans le
cas de son activité quels sont les
critères pour en bénéficier pour en
bénéficier il faut être bénéficiaires du
rsa et avoir un projet de reprise
d'activité donc que ce soit en emploi
salarié en formation rémunérée ou dans
le cas d'une création d'activité plus de
4600 personnes ont pu bénéficier de ce
dispositif
depuis le lancement en octobre 2020 et
j'encourage vraiment toute personne
volontaire au rsa est volontaire pour
retrouver une activité à s'adresser à
nos services pour en bénéficier mais si
terry merci maroni
[Musique]
avec ce contrat d'engagement le
département est aussi dans une démarche
d'accompagnement les bénéficiaires
soient régulièrement suivis par les
agents de la collectivité ce qui lui a
permis de s'inscrire durablement le
monde y cas aujourd'hui bonjour alors
comment se passe votre activité depuis
le lancement avait vous réussi à
maintenir votre qui faisait peur alors
qu'un sommaire plus j'avance plus
sereinement dans l'épanouissement de
l'entreprise et me permet d'avoir un
chiffre d'affaires je vous souhaite
bonne chance pour la suite de votre
parcours et je vous dis à très bientôt
merci a bientot
si vous souhaitez avoir plus
d'information sur le dispositif est plus
n'hésitez pas ils avaient toutes les
coordonnées qui s'affiche à votre écran
le département des générations défini
vous étés on va voir cet épisode un
cycle dépit des précédents rendez vous
sur le site et une aux réseaux sociaux
quant à moi qui vont très vite pour un
nouvel épisode à bientôt
[Musique]
la semaine prochaine je vous emmène à la
découverte de l'académie des dalons cet
accompagnement du département s'adresse
aux jeunes sans emploi qui cherchent à
s'insérer dans la vie active grâce à ce
dispositif ils reprennent confiance en
eux et en leurs compétences
[Musique]